[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: BigQuery is a
fully managed data warehouse
that provides incredibly fast
SQL analytics over large data
sets.
BigQuery provides
more than 100 data
sets publicly
available to analyze,
covering a variety
of data types,
from historical weather to taxi
trips taken in New York City.
We try to offer utility data
sets, such as the US census
data, so that customers can
join these data without needing
to import them.
While these data sets are being
used in vital decision-making
across enterprises,
they are also
a great place to get
started with analyzing data
in BigQuery.
Get started by navigating
to the Google Cloud console
at console.cloud.google.com.
If you are new to Google
Cloud and BigQuery,
use the video linked in
the description below
to set up a new project
in the BigQuery sandbox.
No credit card is required.
Open the navigation window
and select Marketplace.
In the left-hand menu, click
to filter by data sets.
Each tile represents
a public data set.
For example, the
American Community Survey
is an ongoing
survey that collects
social, economic, housing
and demographic data
by surveying more than 3 and 1/2
million US households annually.
In addition to being used in
governmental funding decisions,
private businesses
also find this data
useful in their own
strategic decision-making.
Clicking on the tile
will provide you
more detail on the
data set, including
a description of the data set,
sample queries, and metadata
showing information,
such as when
the data set was last updated,
and if there's a regular update
frequency.
To access the data set, click
the View Data Set button.
This opens a new console
window and brings you
to the data set in
the BigQuery web UI.
You can see each of the tables
available within the data set.
In fact, you can scroll through
the other public data sets
in the program here as well.
Back to the ACS data set.
Click on a table, and you
will see the schema or columns
available in that table,
along with the table details,
including the size
and number of rows,
and a preview of the
first few rows of data.
Click Query Table
and a template will
appear in the Query
Editor, which already
references the selected table.
If you'd rather start with
one of the sample queries,
you can also click the Run this
Query button from the Details
page you were
looking at earlier.
Let's look at this one.
How has King County rent cost
as a share of median income
changed between 2011 and 2017?
In the Query Editor, click Run.
And in just a few
seconds, you have a table
showing how the rent as a
percentage of median income
has changed for each
zip code in the county.
Looking to analyze data
without writing SQL?
Just highlight
the table you wish
to analyze in the left-hand
nav, click Export,
and choose Explore in
Data Studio, Google's data
visualization tool.
BigQuery charges for storage
and offers pay-as-you-go,
on-demand pricing or flat rate
pricing for predictability when
querying data.
You can also take advantage
of the free tier option
to quickly get started.
Use the BigQuery sandbox to stay
safely within the free tier.
More info on how to get started
in the BigQuery sandbox linked
in the description below.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]